we've already seen one definition of the
definite integral and and many of them
are closely related to this definition
that that we've already seen is well
look the definite integral from a to b
of f of x d of x is this area shaded in
blue and we can approximate it by
splitting it into
n
into n
rectangles so let's say that's the first
rectangle
one
that's the second rectangle two and
you're going to go all the way to the
nth rectangle so this would be the n
minus 1 rectangle and for the sake of
this argument i'm going to make in this
video and we're going to assume that
they're all the same width so this is
the nth rectangle and they all have the
same width and we see their definitions
of integration where you don't have to
have the same width here but let's say
that each of those widths are delta x
and the way that we calculate delta x
is we take b minus a
we take b minus a and we divide it by n
we divide it by n which is common sense
or this is what you learned in division
we're just taking this length and
dividing it by n to get and equal
spacings which is or n equal spacings of
delta x and so if you do this you say
okay we've seen this multiple times you
can approximate it
you can approximate this area using this
rect these rectangles as the sum
from i equals one to n so you're summing
your your each of the you're summing n
of these rectangles areas where the
height of the the air the height of each
of these rectangles are going to be f of
x sub i
where x x sub i is the
point at which you're taking the
function value to find out its height so
that could be x sub 1 x sub 2 x sub 3 so
on and so forth
and you're multiplying that times your
delta x times your delta x so you take x
sub 2
f of x sub 2 is that height right there
f of x sub 2
is that height right there you multiply
it times delta x
you get the area and we saw that when we
looked at riemann sums and using that to
approximate and we said hey the definite
the one definite definition of the
definite integral is that since this is
the area this is going to be the limit
as n approaches infinity of this where
where
delta x is defined as that so let me
just copy and paste that
so copy and paste
where that so that's one way to think
about it
now given this definition
what do you think
what do you think this or maybe another
way to think about how do you think
this expression that i'm writing right
over here
based on this definition should relate
to this expression
so notice all i've done is i've going
instead of going from a to b
i'm now going from b
to a i'm now going from b to a how do
you think these two things should relate
and i encourage you to look at all of
this to come to that conclusion and
pause the video to do so
well let's just think about what's going
to happen this is
this is going to be if i were to
literally just take this
if i were to literally just take this
and copy and paste it which i mean which
is exactly what i'm going to do
if i just took this
by definition since i swapped these two
bounds i am going to want to swap
these two instead of b minus a it's
going to be a minus b now
it's going to be
it's going to be a
minus b
so each of these are going this value
right over here let me make these color
coded maybe so this orange delta x
this orange delta x is going to be the
negative of this green
of this green delta x this is the
negative of that right over there
so and everything else is the same
so what am i going to end up doing well
i'm essentially going to end up having
the negative value of this
so this is going to be equal to
the negative of the integral from a to b
of f of x
dx
and so this is the result we get which
is another really important integration
property that if you swap if you swap
the bounds of integration and it really
just comes from this idea instead of
delta x being b minus a if you swap the
bounds of integration it's going to be a
minus b you're going to get the negative
delta x or the negative of your original
delta x which is going to give you the
negative of this original value right
over here and once again this is a
really really useful integration
property where you're trying to make
sense of some integrals and even
sometimes solve some of them